[Music]
let us uphold the flame for fairness and
justice
there's a type of fire there that cannot
be extinguished I'm Eunice Ferreira and
I'm MLK visiting professor and I'm
hosted by the music and Theater Arts
Department
[Music]
one of the things that we talk a lot
about in Black theater and that I impart
to my students and share with them is
the importance of legacy
it's a part of my own cultural heritage
of honoring those who came before you
and how do we make a more just path a
wider path an easier path for those who
will come after
I'm working on my monograph which is
called criolu performance remapping
Creole and mixed race theater it will be
the first full-length study in English
on Cape Verdean theater and I have a
second book project called applied
theater and racial Justice radical
imaginings for just communities applied
theater is using theater for the
purposes of health education using
theater to create communities using
theater for personal growth and
development using theater to engage
students in critical thinking and
problem solving the intervention that
we're making in the book is that by POC
folks black indigenous and people of
color have been doing this work long
before the term itself was coined
whether it's dance or music or acting
reciting poetry as a means to to bring
people together
[Music]